[Music]
[Applause]
uh we spoke to uh Kurt Russell and Wyatt
Russell uh two days ago they have a show
called Monarch Legacy of monsters on
Apple TV plus new episodes coming out
every Friday and uh here is how we
started the
interview it's Kurt and Wyatt Russell
joining us and they have a new series on
Apple TV plus it is called Monarch
Legacy of Monsters new episodes coming
out every Friday all right let me know
how this sounds to you guys I'm want to
be the voice over a guy if you need one
even if you don't need one following the
thunderous battle between Godzilla and
the Titans that leveled San Francisco
and the shocking Revelation that
monsters are real Monarch Legacy of
monsters tracks two siblings following
in their Father's Footsteps who uncover
their family's connection to the secret
organization known as monarch
what do you
think not bad I would slow it down a tou
oh you would have oh okay for okay yeah
because the faster you go the more less
you give a obviously
so I it was just for for time that was
all I was worried about you guys with
with that a nice that was a nice 30
seconds yeah I like that uh you know uh
in a world like I always wanted to be
there in a world that was that Don L
Fontaine one man yeah love that uh WHYY
when you saw uh Kurt play Albert or
Albert Brooks Mel her
Brooks you know I I nobody saw the Mel
Brooks
thing and you were great you were great
not as good as Albert Brooks but you
were great okay when you saw him play
herb Brooks what did you did you ever
have a coach who was like
that no I wish I did to be honest I mean
herb was a legendary coach
my dad uh you know I think he said
before he can talk to it better was
doing his father Bing who was a lot like
herb uh who but it was in the baseball
world I think the better for me I was a
little distant from the process um
because I I was playing at the time and
um we we we there was some fun stuff
actually he would come out and practice
with us do some skating around watch us
interact and he there was a lot from the
film and Gavin OK Conor the director as
well would come some of the games being
the locker room so there was a little
bit of overlap but more of of what was I
guess a testament to how good he was in
that film was when her Herb's grandkids
saw the movie they thought they were
looking at Grand at you know they but
why it was Wyatt's first year up there
playing in in uh playing Junior Hockey
in Canada and they came to me and they
said the beginning of the movie is Young
herb you think Wyatt would do it he said
don't even ask him he's not here he's
not here to work in movies he's here
he's here trying to earn a job on these
teams and move forward in hockey so
don't bother would you have taken them
up on the offer if they ask you why no
they did no they did oh they did okay
yeah no I mean we we were we had a good
it was a second year we we we had a good
team we ended up we ended up second in
Canada that year uh finishing second in
Nationals and we had a really good team
and that my career path was hockey so it
was like this was a very important time
and we did have a couple players
actually leave the team to go be on be
in the movie okay and uh and they wanted
to come back when the movie was done and
be on the team again and it was like no
way dude sorry you left you left you
left this team to go join a different
one and it doesn't matter that it was a
movie wasn't our team so we it was it
was a little bit of a thing um because
it was such a big deal in Vancouver at
the time they getting a lot of hockey
players and they were paying these guys
money that they hadn't been paid before
so it was it was but it was fun
sometimes we'd play uh we'd have a game
in like abbottford and they shot at
abbottford right after we'd play so we'd
have like the crew in the stands and
then we'd end the game and then my dad
would come to work on the same ice that
I just played on that was kind of fun
they help him find a lot of the
locations actually I turned that movie
down quite a few times because it was
relatively uninteresting in the form
that it was in but uh I was up there um
you know because Wyatt was playing
hockey there I was going to be playing
hockey there for a number of years wow
and so I knew all the you know all the
ranks that they could you know possibly
use in the time of year that would work
and whatnot so ended up doing the movie
because actually because Gavin oconor
and I had great conversations about
having hockey players play the play the
uh the characters in the movie um I you
know Sports movies are tough they
they're really tough i' I've never done
a baseball one um and uh depends on the
story and and really it generally their
Sports stories are written by fans
they're not written by players and has a
completely different mindset said coming
out of the players uh from The Players
Point of View than there is a fans point
of view and uh I you know very few are
made by people who either played the
game or played some some high level or
professional level of of the game and
those are usually much better how many
takes for that
speech how many takes that did you need
well it's interesting there's a lot of
rewriting there um uh not that many um
had a couple cameras rolling and and
Yeah the speech I forgot about that um
it was fortunately I had opportunity to
speak with her before that so I felt
very good about the fact that when the
players on the team saw that that movie
they they did refer to the speech and
say how did you know that you know
because I'd spoken with her um the
speech was quite different in fact um
before we actually filmed it and uh I
don't know you know we did like a normal
amount three or four takes and and I
must say there was one line in it that
it came to me at one time which was um
it's like those line reading things
which you never think about but this is
this is your time that that was sort of
the that was sort of the impetus of the
speech and I was just looking at those
guys and I just said this is your time
you know it's not their time anymore
it's your time and that became what what
came out of that what came out of that
pregame speech my my my favorite story
that that would never which we can't I
can't tell it here either I suppose but
was not that speech but the speech that
herb gave I should say the speech that
herb didn't give for the last game after
they beat the Russians they had to play
Finland and I think it was Finland that
they they had to beat for the that win
for the go you can tell the story okay
well anyway from what it was is her said
nothing came in the room said nothing
started to walk out of the room got to
the door turned around and he said if
you lose this game you'll take it to
your grave and he turned around and
walked
out I wanted to shoot that and have no
sound of my voice but you know have herb
have herb already narrating the ending
of the movie but you can you can read
his lips that would have been awesome in
the credits would great yeah oh what do
you think when you see
slapshot Slap Shot was like wasn't as
unaccurate as people might think it
would be that's there's an amazing story
about that slapshot was written by a
woman whose brother was in the Portland
Mavericks locker room he was I think he
was a player on the team can't remember
because this is a long time ago and the
Portland Mavericks were a team that was
the template the Portland Mavericks
which my dad and I my dad owned and
batter Bastards of Baseball is a
documentary you can see um if you have
it on Netflix that um is about that team
it was the most successful minor league
team in the history of the game it was
actually very interesting uh situation
and and uh he was on that team that was
a lot of that a lot of that was derived
from his experience with the Portland
Mavericks which I guess he shared with
his
sister well but you guys were all in
like believable I mean the fact that
Paul Newman took that job like I'm just
going that wasn't as like oie oorp was
like based off person
yeah especially back in the 70s like
that was not that was I mean obviously
there there was it was caricaturized but
but it it wasn't that far off yeah
that's
a blast of a movie I mean you can't come
on there's too much great stuff in that
that's fabulous uh Monarch Legacy of
monsters on Apple TV plus so summarize
this what what have we missed so far and
uh where are we headed with
this well we we uh well you go you're
better explain it's this is you know all
the movies have a there's a there's a
Godzilla lore of course and um this is
connected to that but this is much more
about the people who are now dealing
with this with the reality that monsters
are in and amongst us and we have to
live with them and try to figure out a
way what what is it we're going to do so
this this uh Monarch was uh created back
in the late 40s and early 50s uh by
three people and the character that
Wyatt the character that Wyatt and I
play uh was sort of the the guy who was
coming in from the military side and he
he was the one who needed to sort of
become a Believer as it were that that
uh company Monarch grew and grew but
then fell apart and became something
very different this story is about the
mystery of those people and how it
happened and the fact that what what
what you're looking at here is what are
these monsters what they are real where
they're not dinosaurs where do they come
from where did they why is it we can't
see them what they're very very
mysterious in and amongst themselves and
so it deals with that it's all about
it's all about this family uh finding
out um their history their their their
history having to do with this and it's
and it goes back and forth from the 50s
up to 2014
2015 uh and that's when when I that's
when I play this character Lee Shaw
Wyatt plays him all all through the 50s
do you believe in
Monsters I believe in
Godzilla
you know with this there's there's
there's human monsters and there's uh
and there's animal monsters that's kind
of a lot of what's behind what we're
doing here my guys that I work with
loved uh the movie used
cars Erie yeah my favorite movie is it
really yeah it's like it's so I mean
there's there's I could quote every line
from from the movie we we like weird
used cars just come up like on this
little press store we were doing like a
100 times because it was Bob the second
movie it was my favorite movie of his
it's the closest to his humor to my
dad's humor that I know it's just
everything about that movie to me is
perfect what were you a used car
salesman in Arizona yeah yeah yeah no I
mean it's one of my the most you know
like character-wise I I had fun every
day I mean it was just a blast and those
guys boob Bob Zas and Bob Gail and all
the cast guys too and when when people
that were in the show Deborah it was
just it was just one of those I learned
lot about comedy and how comedy is made
by the people who were involved with
that show I didn't really know that much
about comedy you know you'd read a
script and you go play it but these guys
created comedy they they they they were
fantastic they're you know they went on
to have obviously a lot of great careers
and stuff too yeah it's one thing to see
something written but then you got to
kind of capture what's written and and
and make it work and that's the genius
and this was this was like 1979 1980
period so it was there was a lot of the
the the Second City the second City
people you know that that seemed to be
the core of where a lot of these people
were coming from John Candy was supposed
to be in that movie and he actually
ended up taking his agent took two jobs
at one time W would you recreate used
cars with dad's permission what's that
me yeah I do it in a different way but I
I know what I
do I do it in a different way but I know
what I I what I do because I think
there's a lot of uh fun to be had if
Rudy was like we talked about last night
uh running for he actually did become a
senator and what happened and and I have
a dream about you you produced take too
long this would be great get your dad it
would I agree get someone call somebody
Netflix Dan you know get Mom yeah I'll
call I'll call Sandler I'll call Sandler
yeah I think you'd have to get a hold of
Bob's and Megas
before we run out of time I got question
I have questions for you oh okay uh
first of all I have a great this was so
this is tomorrow's show this is today's
show but we were I was watching tomorrow
yesterday's show uh great a statue
doesn't have a Hall of Fame Dustin Brown
of the LA Kings oh he's a statue outside
Staples Center not going to be in the
Hall of Fame not a Hall of Famer why
didn't you guys know
that I can't know
everything I only came up I only came up
with um was there at one time a statue
of of Sylvester Stallone as Rocky bboa
in front of a stadium I think it's just
on the steps is it just on the steps
there never was one there there was
never another one I don't think that
it's outside of any of their venues and
then I think Sylvester I think there's
two of those statues I think he had one
at his house in
Hollywood he does it was out by the pool
he's got his statue I'm not
joking I'll tell him I'll tell him you
said that and he'll get
one how would Goldie feel if you said
I'd like to have a statue outside of the
home
H should divorce them even though
they're not okay what what what other
question do you have what anything else
so we always we always talk about we
always have the debate of of who should
be in the hall of fame or not we talk
about like adium okay and more
interesting Sports more interesting one
that we're always like God should this
person be in the hall of fame or not is
golf golf the Golf Hall of Fame is a
hard one and the real one is like Fred
Couples he's got one major yeah but only
I think 15 wins and it's like is that a
Hall of Fame golf
career what is the criteria when it
comes to numbers versus the reason for
for fame I think it's like he had a lot
of reason for fame you could win one
Super Bowl like Freddy won one Super
Bowl he won the Masters and is that
enough to get into the hall now you can
also do contributions to the game as
well he's been on the senior tour the
champions tour the longevity part of
that uh look into the future of golf
that's going to open up a lot of guys a
lot of guys to the Hall of Fame what
about Cabrera no I think what's going to
happen though Kurt is because a Liv tour
these guys might not be playing in
Majors so guys that would be having a
Hall of Fame career are just going to be
financially comp compensated and they're
not going to have the majors there or
will you take into consideration the
fact that they win 40 whatevers no
around the world you know on live on
live tour no but you guys should do a
podcast if if if the live if the live
tour hold on if the live tour how would
you guys do as a podcast do you think
you guys just Sports could you put up
with each other have time in the day oh
God you're actors that's not true all we
do we just sit around nothing you're
actors you got time
it's so true but if if the Liv tour if
John ROM goes to the Liv tour for real
and they change the rules and they they
change it to a four day turn because
that's the big sticking point put it
make it four days don't do the weird
shotgun start thing yeah and then and
then they start being able to compete
for the world golf rankings then that
changes that to know what the story is
behind live PGA because you know I can
do a little conspiracy theory on that
one like uh you know in the old days of
the AFL and the NFL when the AFL was
created you know that was a terrible
terrible thing who's going to go over
there and all of that you know it they
became what they became and then nameth
win nameth Hall of he should be in the
Hall of Fame for what he of course
because of what he did he brought two
leagues together yeah is that what's
gonna happen with Liv and the PGA was
that always the intent I keep thinking
that eventually that you got to bring it
together that they have to merge well
well if if if you're if you're you know
sitting around with Greg Norman seven
eight years ago you you think that
conversation might have been had by a
few people well he brought it up I
wouldn't say no he he brought it up 30
years ago this idea so he'd been
thinking about it for a while best way
to do this and why not create two and
then we'll we'll maybe we'll have a
we'll have a competition and then
eventually it'll always be the it'll be
the PGA but it will be a lot larger than
it was you guys don't want to talk
movies you want to talk sports right no
no no we never talk movies no we talk
about this so you can go make
them but why have you told dad that I've
been in 20 Sandler movies just I don't
know if he if you checked out I mean
maybe you know that I don't know Kurt
but I've been in 20 I think I've said to
my dad I'm like I think Dan would be
good in in like a real drama yeah like
you you need to get in like a you need
to get in like a real drama where you
could use your low tamber wait what the
why didn't I get in this B by the way
you should have been announcing a game
while Godzilla get
yes Dan we talked about this but there's
enough monsters all already so oh okay I
can be something less than a monster oh
oh I see you want to play a human oh
okay Kurt it's great to have you on
we've always appreciated Wyatt and uh
especially when he showed up in person
with flip flops a Parker a winter hat
and I went we're in we're in Los Angeles
what are you doing it was cold you had
flipflops on he's bare my feet i' got
eczema
all right whenever there's a real tough
topic and I need to be the guy who comes
in settles it then you guys let me know
we'd love to have you come back on
perfect deal once again it's called
Monarch Legacy of monsters Apple TV plus
new episodes airing every Friday hey 93%
on Rotten Tomatoes good for you good for
you who are those 7% we're going after
you thank you guys all right good talk
you Dan see you Kurt and Wyatt Russell a
lot of fun talking to them